for those who are counting there are 13
days officially remaining in this
administration
but this morning there are calls for
president trump to once again be
impeached or
and we do not say this lightly for the
cabinet to invoke the 25th amendment
removing him from office because
he is on fit according to our sources
the president for his part is still
clueless about how outrage and i would
add heartsick americans were as they
watched the violence unfold yesterday
that reporting comes from our cbs news
white house team talking not to the
president's
enemies but to his allies ben tracy is
at the white house for us ben good
morning to you
this talk of removing the president from
power prematurely
how likely is it well tony good morning
cbs news has learned that members of the
cabinet are discussing the 25th
amendment but have not formally
presented anything to vice president
pence yet
about removing president trump from
office now president trump watched all
of this chaos at the capitol unfold on
television here at the white house
yesterday
and he's taking no responsibility for
any of it
you have to go home now we have to have
peace
nearly three hours after his supporters
stormed the capitol
president trump finally released a
one-minute long video telling them to go
home
but also making it clear how he really
feels about the violent mob
we love you you're very special he then
justified their actions saying these
things happen when a sacred landslide
election victory
is so unceremoniously and viciously
stripped away
twitter locked the president's account
for 12 hours and is threatening to
permanently ban him
i call on president trump
to go on national television now as
hours of chaos pass without president
trump speaking
president-elect biden called on him to
be a leader
at their best the words of a president
can inspire
at their worst they can incite
all four living former presidents
expressed their outrage
george w bush called the attack on the
capitol insurrection
saying in a statement i am appalled by
the reckless behavior of some political
leaders since the election
this is how election results are
disputed in a banana republic
not our democratic republic president
trump's former defense secretary general
james mattis
directly blamed him for the violence
predicting mr trump will deservedly be
left a man
without a country the president is also
now completely at odds with vice
president pence
madam speaker members of congress
attacking him for following the
constitution
and refusing to try to overturn the
election i hope he doesn't listen to the
rhinos and the stupid people that he's
listening to
now several white house aides have
resigned overnight including the
president's deputy national security
adviser
matt pottinger and the first lady's
chief of staff and former white house
press secretary stephanie grisham
who we're told resigned in protest now a
senior white house official tells cbs
news
that they feel the administration's
legacy has been tarnished by what
happened
at the capitol tony ben thank you very
much